is Senor Presidente the concealer mr.
prime minister of the Republic of Italy
thank you for having accepted the
invitation from the European Parliament
to join us this afternoon with a view to
setting at your vision of the future of
Europe and that of the Italian
government Italy being of course one of
the founding members of the European
Union and we're proud to have the
opportunity to debate with you this
afternoon on the major issues facing 500
million people as you know the European
Parliament is involved in working a
whole series of issues to direct
relevance to European citizens we are
the beating hearts of democracy in the
European Union the only directly elected
body in the Union and we have and
continue to fight hard to see an
increase in the budget of the European
Union from 1.1 to 1.3 percent of own
resources we have also made the choice
of adopting a clear stance on the
question of immigration the European
Parliament is in favour of stepping up
investment on the African continent to
address the issue upstream we've also
adopted a strong position on refugees
months ago the European Parliament
adopted its proposal which is now on the
council's table
we would ask you to push for the
adoption of this text which we think
could go a great way to alleviating
tension in the countries along the
southern borders of the European Union
those countries which have been most
sorely hit by migration on brexit the
European Parliament lays great emphasis
on the need to provide protection for
British citizens living in Brussels on
major infrastructure we've adopted a
large increase of funding so it's to
ensure that funding of European
infrastructure can feed into a higher
growth and as far as foreign and defence
policy is concerned we have recently
voted to call on the Member States to
represent to recognize the interim
president of Venezuela in line with the
constitution of that country next the
next issue which I know is part of yeren
government's manifesto the European
Parliament calls for enhanced powers the
power to put forward elective
initiatives like any other Parliament in
the world and these are rights which are
actually enshrined in the treaties which
we which we haven't yet been able to
exercise so Prime Minister I would like
now to give you the floor so that you
can tell us more about the thinking of
the Italian government on the future of
the European Union thank you
in Tampa today registrar apparel catch
the icon in the meantime members may
launch with a request to speak and to
catch the ice session with the Italian
Prime Minister immediately after his
intervention Honorable President
italiani
president Ayane vice president catenin
ladies and gentlemen members of the
European Parliament ladies and gentlemen
it's a real honor for me to be here
today and I say that sincerely here
before you to set out and foreshadow
something about Europe's future as seen
from the perspective of the Italian
government thinking about this
commitment to the future of our
continent I would like to recall Antonio
mega Litzy with emotion an Italian who
declared himself to be in love with the
European Union and who fell as your well
note here two months ago in Strasbourg
from a barbaric terrorist attack in a
globalized world in which the economy
seems to have taken the upper hand over
politics and law and where economic
choices made a long way away can have an
impact on our citizens we must ask
searching questions about how the
European Union is undertaking its role
the role that can play take into account
that the nation-states and the member
states alone are no longer capable of
responding to these global challenges
this common European construct as we all
know is going through an especially
critical phase the European project
seemed to have lost its momentum
the complex history behind us
represented by the institutions and the
roles and challenges we all have lead us
to tackle crucially important topics as
in the past those who preceded us in
just as critical a phase we like them
must make a joint effort with a full
sense of responsibility it's our role to
get the European project up and running
again lending it cohesion and
credibility increasing its
sustainability and effectiveness and
prospects the challenges we face are new
and complex ones and they require vision
and if you allow me to say I think they
require a touch of creativity but above
all they require awareness of our
mission in the world the major questions
that we all must answer are ones of
meaning what Europe do we want what
Europe do we need how do we see
ourselves and how do we represent
ourselves these are questions that
search our conscience and require the
greatest concentration and the most
genuine answers because we are here in
the European Parliament directly elected
by the citizens of the European Union
and the repository of European
sovereignty we must above all be a
people the people of Europe progressive
advances in integration have genuinely
made us a people a community of destiny
above and beyond any legal formalities
the idea of constructing a European
people has gone through significant
periods of
the history of modern contemporary
Europe is marked by deep divisions and
contrasts which have gone to forge a
degree of popular belonging languages
cultures and traditions nonetheless this
cross-cultural legal cross fertilization
is going on we've seen areas of
sovereignty and we've seen a transfer of
powers increasingly from countries to
the Union and we've allowed citizens of
a number of member states to be able to
move freely within the territory of
Europe which is conceived as a single
legal space free movement of people more
than the free movement of goods and
capital has been one of the most
significant achievements in the process
of European integration just thinking in
terms of the identity politics that has
shaken the continent from the late 19th
century to the mid 20th century and the
two world conflagrations the Europeans
above all the youngest ones do not
intend to give up that fundamental
freedom to move thanks to which such
significant measures and natural
measures unknown to past generations has
led to them sharing their heritage of
their culture and their professional
activities enriching their national
identities within this sensitivity and a
sense of belonging together the process
of creating a people of Europe is one
that has fed on the legal dimension to
which has matured over a period of
civilization building in which law has
played a great part in forging a common
identity and a European demos in that
respect the role played by each of us
each of our institutions including the
Court of Justice and the Court of Human
Rights has been vital and they've played
a very key role in a close relationship
with national constitutional courts
that's created a European legal space in
which citizens can seek protection and
recognition and this refined and full
system provides many levels of human
rights based on constitutional
traditions this system of legal
protection is now one that I would say
is written indelibly in the legal
heritage of the EU and that is a great
civilizational achievement which needs
to be protected and defended precisely
because the beneficial effects it has in
the collective self perception of
European citizens increasing their
awareness that they belong to a shared
destiny that they belong to a people in
the sense of a community belonging in
the same productive civilizational
process despite all that however we
haven't yet succeeded in genuinely and
fully becoming a people we haven't had
the courage yet to build up an inclusive
model which realistically above and
beyond any rhetoric really creates a
genuine European demos especially when
you think back to 1989 I know there are
exceptions to this but there was a lack
of a really political vision for the
European Union a long term prospect
directed to the future without which any
project just runs into the ground and
every dream fades away
and falls into bread and butter
administration and some of the optimism
of the post-war period fades away now
over the last 30 years European
governance has been strongly anchored
solely in the economic dimension and
there hasn't been full rein given to the
freedoms there's been privatization of
essential goods and services and there
has been regulation deregulation in
vital economics sectors there's been a
reduction of social support and welfare
policies and these have as a whole led
to increased inequalities in terms of
wealth an opportunity above all with the
economic crisis European governance has
supported austerity policies geared up
entirely to raining in sovereign debt
within given parameters and keeping the
inflation rate of the common currency as
low as possible and even against the
background of a drop in consumption and
that's how devastating social effects
European policy faced with an economic
crisis without precedent has withdrawn
fearfully into procedural ISM and it's
progressively lost contact with its
people and it's made it harder than ever
to make up that distance which isn't a
geographic distance between Brussels and
the continents periphery and
progressively ineluctably this policy
has lost its representative
justification and there's been a kind of
oligarchic system where the real needs
of society have been ignored and I've
seen this
recognized by Anna golonka there's been
a ceremonial path taken by complex
processes which have happened behind the
scenes if not in secrecy and I think
this issue with the European people visa
vie the elites speaks to our conscience
politics has failed to do its job in
parts of the economy and has failed to
see its mission through and we now face
a decisive crossroads in the history of
a united Europe and fundamental
decisions await us as regards our future
this European people on history stage is
urgently calling to be listened to
finally to be listened to and there must
be a decisive change of method and of
outlook this I believe is a precious
opportunity to make up lost time to turn
around the process of increasing
distance between the governed and the
government and the silence and the
indifference that there has been or
temptations to make less of some of the
implosion so that we've seen across the
world we shouldn't be afraid of conflict
we should have the confidence to govern
it and we shouldn't have sterile
conservatism geared up entirely to
defend the besieged Citadel quite to the
contrary we must look at democracy and
see its momentum its ability to break
out with new forms of innovation and to
drop old securities and come up with
models of development and growth that
replace the ones that have shown that
they're not capable of dealing with the
new challenges
and society has been left with
loneliness and insecurity and these
feelings are ones that come from the
neglected and they can fade
unpredictability and we've seen that in
what's going on in a number of European
countries the European ISM of the 21st
century will necessarily require us
radically to rethink the sort of
institutions that have been the hallmark
of integration over the last 30 years
they urgently require overhaul and in
some respects that means going back to
the roots to the founding reasons for
the European dream the Europe that we
are imagining and must be capable of
generating momentum it shouldn't just
stabilize things in the interests of its
citizens and member states and common
interests geopolitics is in rapid flux
and new strategic equilibriums are
marked by a great degree of fluidity
fluidity and we need to think in terms
of how certain areas of the world
rapidly increasing their influence and
in that connection no member state alone
can play a significant role
hence the wish that there should be a
united European voice that should be
able to speak including in the UN
Security Council that's a fight that the
European Union will have to wage in a
coordinated way in order to be able to
speak with one voice the European Union
needs to be able to speak to the world a
european union that is strong that is
ambition and that is cohesive is
required to enhance its ability to talk
to the United States and as I said my
first speech in the European and the
Italian parliament we strongly believe
in the transatlantic
together with Washington we need to
continue to operate to preserve the
strategic values inherent in our
relationship and the things that unite
us weigh heavily in terms of values and
principles compared to any possible
disagreement or misunderstanding and at
one at the same time a strong European
Union is needed in terms of credibility
with the dialog with key stakeholders in
the world Russia and dialogue key
players in every international crisis
starting with those closest to our
borders affecting European interests the
EU will gain nothing by forgoing
dialogue with Russia or China or if it
believes that it can promote an
isolationist stance as regards them we
should promote their engagement at all
levels but how can that be done how can
we achieve a strong Europe and we all
share the need for it well certainly we
should carry on with integration of
European defense we should exploit all
the potential within permanent
structured cooperation pesco and
European defense a European common
defense is not only not at odds with
NATO but can be complementary with NATO
with the EU capable of making progress
providing more security to its citizens
and let's not forget that the European
Union which aspires to be a global
player cannot forego close links with
the United Kingdom in security and
defense even after brexit
but the key prerequisite to guarantee a
strong Europe in the world is that above
and below we must promote solidarity and
cohesion there must be shared
responsibility among the Member States
migration and economic and financial
governance
two emblematic challenges showing the
need to restore trust in solidarity in
Europe and we cannot put it off anymore
there must be a substantial substantive
change of Outlook and these principles
should not fall prey to the divisive
dynamic between the Member States on
those key issues which should be part
and parcel of the daily debate in Europe
and bilaterally in these days we've seen
clearly confirmed these these squabbles
not the cause but the effect of a Europe
that's are incapable of meeting its
needs and they cannot take away from the
momentum of the European approach in
migration there are delays it's thanks
to Italy that migration has been put
front and center of the European agenda
Europe cannot go on coping with
migration on an emergency footing we
need to equip ourselves with a
structured approach so that we can have
a stable effective system and on that
note - speaking to this August chamber I
would direct an appeal that is one I
make at every European Council or
informal summit that I've attended we
cannot keep putting off full
implementation of the council
conclusions from the 28th of June last
year without a strategy for managing
migration on a multi-level basis we will
compromise the very fabric of a united
Europe a European strategy for tackling
it on a multi-level basis dealing with
these causes of the movement is vital
otherwise we will see our total
inability to control onward movements
and in the countries where the landings
take place in Europe
we see many landing Europe as a whole is
the Mediterranean this principle should
always be recollected we must look at
migration in the right perspective but
it's important at the same time that
European security is at stake and
support for the political process in
Libya for the process on going in Africa
and the Middle Eastern chess board or in
play
I think the centrality of the
Mediterranean is vital for Europe's
future this is borne out by my visits in
November to Tunisia and Libya and the
conference on the 12th of December last
year and soon I'll be traveling to
Morocco to all this is part of Italy's
comprehensive strategy aimed at
contributing in a systemic way to these
theaters of crisis and we do that in
conjunction with the UN and the EU and
it's not just in the interest of our
country but also of Europe as a whole
Europe must look beyond the
Mediterranean as well and think in terms
of financing for Africa for Africa
otherwise we will only temporarily
staunch the flow of migration but we
will never do more than improve it on
the basis of repatriations that must be
something that works on a coordinated
basis and with development policy where
we need key decisions Italian government
commitments in Africa are based on that
approach
I personally am pursuing it with great
conviction and that's why I went to the
Horn of Africa
and it's going through its own spring
and I went there in a began their spring
and leisure and chaired as well and here
we must promote a new approach to the
problems faced by Africa there must be a
new model of cooperation inspired by a
partnership of equals and we must work
to improve the opportunities and
encourage responsibility on both sides
we cannot remain indifferent to the fact
that the majority of the people in
Africa men women and children are living
in inhuman conditions of poverty despite
the substantial natural resources that
their homelands have we cannot remain
indifferent to the fact that much of the
wealth generated by the economy of
Africa is is channeled through billions
of offshore companies and all goes to
tax havens or benefits our foreign
investors I'm delighted that cooperation
with Africa has been recognized by the
European Commission itself and I'd like
to thank John Claude Younker for his
conviction in driving forward that
objective which is so important for our
future our shared future recognition of
that priority must go hand in hand with
the allocation of adequate financial
resources and the drawing up of new
arrangements for intervention Europe
must commit itself to drawing up a
catalogue of best practice so that we
can find hone a genuinely fair and
sustainable model of cooperation this
will help deal with migration this is
important for Europe's future and we
have to do that in light of the next a
mff 2021 to 2027 Europe must equip
itself with the infrastructure and
finances on a sustainable basis to
govern migration from the countries of
origin and the
through the transit countries and the
Mediterranean Mediterranean route needs
to be given proper attention six billion
euro has been allocated a turkey
agreement by the EU the trust fund for
Africa of the EU is another way of
looking at financing there's at least
half a billion euros missing from the
amounts committed we must also look at
the internal management of migration and
simply shutting down maritime borders
with huge levels of spending on
thousands of Frontex agents and aid for
the countries of landings where
countries of first arrival isn't enough
these migratory flows need a joint
effort they cannot be gathered on their
own and all 28 member states must be
part of this the proposal to reform the
Dublin regulation adopted in November
2017 by the European Parliament is not
sustainable in the current European
Union sadly the bulk of the member
states are not automatically and
mandatorily showing that solidarity
implementation of the 28th of June
council conclusions which are based on
the principles of solidarity and a fair
share out of responsibilities which is
reflected in article 80 of the treaty on
the functioning of the European Union
cannot be put off anymore
faced with human lives which have been
abused broken and sold off we must
together fight a fight that shows no
quarter to the traffickers and this is
enough front to humanity and a threat to
our very security let's cease
division and nationalist or regionalist
thinking and let's put in practice
genuine solidarity
and restore a Europe that respects human
lives as well as its own security the
need for a genuinely shared solidarity
between member states without dividing
the EU into different geographic areas
is reflected by the challenge to
complete economic and monetary union
which is no less of a priority
especially at a time of heightened
global tension which jeopardizes the
economic cycle in Europe as recent GDP
estimates for member states from the
European Commission have shown I hope
that Italy and other southern European
member states will call for a better
balance in terms of risk sharing and
there must be genuine convergence which
doesn't leave growth behind in order to
pursue austerity the commitment to
reform and of course I'm thinking about
that launched by the Italian government
in the 2019 finance bill has to focus on
the social dimension as well as the
economic one otherwise structural
reforms will just become a Sisyphean
task which will kill off social cohesion
in its finance bill Italy has embarked
on a path of growth and stability whilst
putting our accounts in order we are
looking for a better future for citizens
who have been left behind and there must
be this expectation for change at the
same time the Italian government has
tried to encourage public investment by
streamlining the legal and regulatory
framework and that bears witness to this
need to breathe dynamism into an economy
that plays a vital role in our continent
economic governance in the EU must take
into account the need to balance
stability and growth otherwise it will
fall short and even the boost from a
younger plan to growth will fall short
in those circumstances and that is a
concrete sign of Europe's recognition
that public in
is vital to promote investment but what
does this mean to put austerity behind
us we must recognize the need for
financial stability we must commit
ourselves to social stability and
sustainable development as well and I'm
happy that jean claude Younker recently
has referred to the fact that in the
Greek crisis austerity was perhaps
overdone now some of us were convinced
right from the beginning and I think
perhaps a Europe hasn't really reflected
on its inability to deal with migration
and deal with stability in the past and
I think it's important that for tomorrow
Europe more courageously invests in
young people in education in innovation
and it certainly should not
disincentivize public investment
directed at those goals by recognizing
it as a deficit issue it should be seen
as breathing fresh life into the future
of that continent moreover economic
progress and sustainable and balanced
social development should be seen in the
wake of the Maastricht Treaty ten years
after it entered the force the Lisbon
Treaty has goals that are far from being
fulfilled completing the European
architecture is an issue the Commission
and the EIB have taken on board some of
these concerns and that's why on the
21st of January the Eurogroup building
on the summit on the 14th of December
last year has set up a working group to
deal with the European Deposit Insurance
Scheme and the completion of the banking
union banking crisis
that is an area where we've seen some
progress and the high-level group is
going to be taking on that role we need
to change some of the the instruments
that are in place following the banking
resolution problems and banking and
financial stability in Italy and Europe
needs to benefit from that in the
Maastricht Treaty the role of giving
sovereign debtor credibility was based
on a sixty percent debt to GDP ratio for
individual member states and that
required reforms by national governments
however we've seen in the Italian case
that some significant criticisms were
made from the financial crisis and the
global recession from 2008 on I think
we've seen the need to proceed towards
creating common financing instruments at
a European level which will allow us
together to tackle the challenges we
face and that has to marry
responsibility and solidarity the lack
of solidarity in the EU also explains
why Europe finds it so hard to be fairer
and more social their new parliamentary
term must see us pursuing with more
urgency the priority of fighting
unemployment and supporting growth
Europe must be courageous in how it
deals with that such as a European
unemployment insurance and it must fight
against a drift back to nationalism and
a lack of work unemployment especially
youth unemployment in certain
disadvantaged areas of Europe
is causing people to fall back on
nationalism in some areas in particular
the areas that are benefiting are trying
to ensure themselves as these European
problems as if there are a cost and
disadvantaged areas will not be
successful in acquiring the resources
they need to make genuine progress a
fairer Europe with more solidarity
should be our objective for the next
multi-annual financial framework as well
then the complexity of such negotiations
should not see us losing sight of that
priority above all against the backdrop
of the existential challenges that
Europe faces and therefore its decisive
that we have a proper balance between
the new priorities such as migration
growth and investment and security and
traditional policies such as cohesion
and the Common Agricultural Policy we
should go on receiving full support as
they are central in the socio-economic
situation of the continent multi I'll do
this one well let's be there there are
many other challenges that we must
tackle we must commit ourselves to
promote fairer world trade that is
better able to protect consumers we must
undertake every useful initiative to
fight resolutely against climate change
we must continue playing a leadership
role in protecting old rights and new
rights in the digital age bear in mind
that rights cost something I'm thinking
of the decisive role in particular that
European the Europe can play as a
security provider with a view to new
hybrid threats and specifically cyber
threats president ladies and gentlemen
I come back to this question about
meaning what Europe do we want that I
began my speech with how do we intend to
guarantee the citizens of Europe a
future commensurate with the 60 years of
peace and development that the EU has
given them well my answer is that once
again it's the same thing
Europe must be close to its peoples the
European Union in the 21st century must
pursue its project from the people for
the people and I'm happy to restate here
today in the European Parliament that
there must be a heightened role for it
in particular as regards legislative and
investigative powers as the only
institution that enjoys a direct you
democratic legitimacy it's also
important to recognize that the
Parliament should have a heightened role
in terms of accountability visa vie the
other EU institutions the European
Parliament can play a decisive role
faced with the call for change which is
moving through Europe we've seen
historic events in the last decade which
have changed the balance of the
continent geopolitically at the same
time direct democracy must be enhanced
in Europe - that means a vital move to
recover credibility for the institutions
in the eyes of their citizens in EU
there must be widespread recognition of
the disenchantment of their citizens the
government I'm honored to chair seize
this priority in the desire for change
of the citizens of Italy and that hasn't
been offered for a long time including
at an EU level and I think that
requirement for change needs to be
reflected
and that's why we must put in practice
those principles it's enough to think of
brexit an issue which will occupy a
Europe for the years to come faced with
that challenge the EU has shown its able
to act on the basis of unity and
solidarity and to protect the sixty
years plus of European integration
without giving in to a punitive approach
towards a member of the European family
that no longer intends to be part of
that family
this is epoch-making and unprecedented
and first and foremost the concern has
been to protect the rights of citizens
and protect the economic and political
fabric against the negative effects of
brexit president ladies and gentlemen
with courage I think we can move on
seeing how we've acted according to the
treaties resisting the tendency of
things to fragment and in my country too
we've seen that people can fall victim
to disillusionment if we want Europe to
remain our common future then we must
follow words with deeds and set the
route for a new Europe with more
solidarity more inclusion more fairness
and ultimately more democracy the only
one in which citizens are today and in
the future deserve to live
you're accessing your pretty more Thank
You Prime Minister before asking the
vice printer the Commission mr. carton
to speak I would like to remind
everybody just how imported is for us
that member states do their part in
enhancing the powers of the European
Parliament and you refer to this
yourself and as far as migration is
concerned in the next meeting of the
Council we would call for a final push
to ensure that the proposal of the
European Parliament be adopted if
necessary evolving compromises on the
Dublin reform and I think I can speak on
behalf of everybody in the house in
saying that vice-president the
Commission mr. chuka Tina Donny will
present today conceived confident that
one of our members Italy holds a very
special place in the heart of our union
he's given Europe so much and it's been
there from the very start shaping our
union every step of the way
it was Spinelli and Rossi imprisoned on
the island of hven titania who set out a
dream of a free and united Europe they
called on the nations of Europe so long
adversaries to come together to ensure
that the mistakes of the past would
never happen again after the war the
Caspari became one of the great pioneers
of European unity and in 1957 it was on
the Capitoline Hill that the Treaty of
Rome was signed and our union was born
with six founding member states 60 years
on in 2017 it was once again on those
same steps in Rome that the leaders of
our member states stood side-by-side to
renew day vows for our unity this time
there were 27 of them from right across
our continent
of how far we have come I say this
because it is special history is one of
the many reasons that it has such a
unique and important place in our union
but I also say this because it shows
that Europe moves forward that Europe is
at its best when Italy when it does hit
aliy and Italian people and it's beating
heart
this history must serve as a kite and as
a reminder for our future to build a
successful future for our union Europe
needs a strong Italy at its heart just
as strong as vibrant Italy needs a
strong Europe we must build our common
future together in unity and in
solidarity always working with and
against and not against each other
talking with each other and not about
each other
and when it comes to building a true
union of solidarity Italy is the best
place to start it is where the European
solidarity corps started its work to
help Italy repealed following the tragic
earthquakes it suffered 2,000 6230 young
Europeans volunteered in Umbria and
across the region regions hardest hit in
addition to the 1.2 billion years of
financial support provided to Italy
under the EU solidarity fund we all have
seen images of young volunteers from all
over Europe helping to rebuild the
ancient and beautiful Church of norcia
this is the Solidarity that builds our
European Union today and that must
continue to build our common future it
of itself has sown the same spirit
countless time over the years president
Juncker said it said it many times
Italy is one of those who saved Europe's
honour in the Mediterranean at the head
of the migration crisis and the truth is
that some others were too slow to
support the efforts of Italian people
but it's also true that Europe stood up
and supported Italy in every way that it
could
since beginning of the migration crisis
to the end of 2018 the Commission made
almost 950 million years available to
support my crazy and important
management in Italy this includes 225
million years in emergency support to
fund border surveillance and rescue
search and rescue operations to improve
reception facilities and to support all
of the authorities and people on the
crop Europe has been there for Italy and
we should not forget operation Sophia or
the role of European border and coast
code saving lives at sea is
joint effort and here again we need
Italy Prime Minister it's also clear
that Europe still needs to overcome its
differences and find sustainable and
responsible solutions we can no longer
rely on ad hoc solutions we have come a
long way since the peak of the crisis
with arrival down by over 97% in eastern
Mediterranean and 80% in the central
Mediterranean 700,000 lives have been
saved at sea but clearly we now need to
finish the job and conclude the
necessary reform of our Asylum system
Commission has put everything on the
table and it is now time to move ahead
we need the full engagement of Italy if
we want the suit to succeed
one of our members Prime Minister Europe
stands for peace and prosperity and we
are all responsible to defend its value
together that means deciding what we
want Europe to achieve and it means
deciding where to invest and to have the
biggest impact on daily lives of
Italians and all Europeans this is why
last made the Commission put forward a
fair modern and balanced budget photo
for our future a Patchett that is more
efficient and more focused on issues
that matter to most to our people
for instance Commission has proposed an
almost three-fold increase in funding
for my creation and security to reach
nearly 33 billion euro and increased
simply a more effective and more
flexible EU budget for external action
will help build partnership with
countries in our neighborhood and Bureau
this will be especially important for
Italy as a country that has taken so
much responsibility in this area we will
in
in making our economies more competitive
more innovative and productive key for
Italy will be 50% increase in funding
for research and aeration and the nine
billion year digital Europe program that
will support Italy's digital
transformation investing in our future
also involves investing in human capital
through education and training this is
why the Commission has proposed to
propose a doubling of the budget of 30
billion years for the erasmus+ programme
the Eels flagship for learning mobility
we aim to increase support to all
sectors including higher education as
well as vocational education and
training in 2017 more than 65,000
Italians participated to Erasmus
programs in the next modern your
financial model on your budget we will
build on the success of investment plan
for Europe the so-called younger plan
either is one of the largest
beneficiaries of the plan with close to
fifty eight billion years of investment
triggered in Italy's economy and over
215,000 small and medium-sized
businesses supported Janka plan has
increased significantly private
investment but also public investment in
in Italy it's a positive sign because
that we should not put too much burden
on taxpayer if private liquid is
available that investment is making a
real difference on the ground right
across Italy 70 million years is helping
to refurbish the local hospital in
Treviso 200 millions going into
upgrading Pugliese water network to
improve quality and access to clean
drinking water for more than 4 million
people and 500 million is supporting the
rolling out of high speed internet so
that 7 million more household in Italy
benefit from quality protein access
the new program for the next budget
invest EU has the potential to go much
further by triggering altogether 650
billion euro of investment
all of this can and will make a real
difference on the crown in Italy and
across our unit this is especially true
at a time when it can intro this
becoming harder cross some of our major
European economies partly down to global
uncertainties but also because of
domestic challenges and choices economic
truth needs confidence amongst
households and investors Trust is like
oxygen you notice it only when it's
running up uncertainty it's a poison
that seriously hampered chop and crow
chops and growth interest road has been
vehicle than the eurozone average for
many years this is a structural problem
the weaker crowd means fewer jobs for
the Italian people at the same time and
I say every occasion Italy is among the
most creative economies in the world the
future of our of your country is in your
hands do what is necessary to unleash
this creativity and offer a pride a
future for the Italian people honourable
members the Prime Minister it is now two
years since we presented the white paper
on the future of Europe which
kick-started the debate we are having
now on what we want our union achieved
in the years ahead five scenarios show
different possible parts that we could
decide to take but whatever we choose
there are some things that are constant
and one of those is Italy central law
role in building our union Europe needs
a strong Italy and Italy needs a strong
Europe it was not surprised or
coincident that the first lines of the
white paper we're about Spinelli and
Rosie's manifesto so as we look at our
future we should all inspire ourselves
from those that have gone before us to
build a stronger and more united union
for generations that follow just as they
did for us thank you very much Samara
a linter venti